welcome back to New Rockstar's Creed 3
release last Friday and let me tell you
it's phenomenal Jonathan majors and
Michael B Jordan really delivered the
two actors compliment each other so well
and after seeing this you'll want to see
killmonger and Kang really just go at it
the acting choreography and directing
really shows in this movie and gave me
personally the same ambition and
appreciation of the first Creed movie
did I loved this movie I loved all the
parallels the previous films in the
Creed and Rocky franchise I agree with
Jessica the fight choreo and Chemistry
Between the leads make this movie a
knockout yes yes and without further Ado
I'm Jessica Clemens here with my best
friend in the entire world entire
Multiverse Tommy bechtold and we're
gonna break down Creed 3 for you so if
you haven't seen it we're going to be
spoiling this is just your Warner this
is your warning yes we're huge fans of
the Creed movies Tommy's a huge Rocky
fan so it made sense for us to just
break down this bad boy together we love
Adonis we love Apollo so let's get it
started one of my favorite parts of the
Creed movies are the time jumps that are
pretty seamless we learned that Adonis
and Jonathan Major's character Damien
Anderson go way back to being Brothers
in a group home and their Foster father
Leon beating them as a child when put
into a sticky situation Adonis beat up
Leon outside of a convenience store and
was immediately jumped by Leon's friends
so Damien pulled a gun on them but the
cops arrived they took Damian away and
Adonis ran Damien spent 18 years in
prison watching Adonis become what he
always wanted to be the world's greatest
boxer so the entire relationship between
Adonis and Damien stems from the
unresolved pent-up anger due to their
past ding ding round two fast forward 15
years or so later and after beating
Conlin the Irish boxer from the first
movie Adonis goes into retirement quick
note it's unbelievable how much Adonis
looks it moves like Apollo in this movie
damn it was like seeing Carl Weathers in
1983 all over again besides Conlin we
also have Bianca played by Tessa
Thompson little Duke played by Wood
Harris Mary and Creed played by Felicia
Rashad my man Stitch who's in every
single movie whose name is Stitch in
real life we even had Victor Drago
himself returning last time we saw Drago
was of course in Creed two we also get
cameos from real life Fighters Canelo
Alvarez Terence Crawford is Nightmare
and Jessica mccaskill as for Donnie he's
done he's Now setting up fights training
new boxers and being a phenomenal dad
that is until Damien shows up yes and
like Jonathan Majors Kang Damien has
lost a lot of time he wants to make up
for that time this is an important thing
in the movie because Adonis is aging
he's in retirement Damian lost his time
in prison he wants it back quickly they
both spend so much time angry and
confused at each other and blinded who
they were coogler has always been good
at writing this he's always been good at
writing villains because they're not
really villains we see Damon's point of
view in justification we know the fuel
and passion he has for boxing it wasn't
a dream it was his dream if you lost all
that time protecting your brother to see
how far he's come doing what you dreamed
of doing every day from your youth of
being locked in a Cell you're gonna be
mad you'll be confused about where to
put that anger this motivation really
pushed Damien until the end of the movie
and I think he's such a well-written
character that's just so blinded by his
own ambition ding ding ding round three
he had reason to be upset Jessica Damien
reached out to Adonis multiple times but
Adonis never received any letters
because sweet sweet Marianne was keeping
the two separated to rekindle an old
friendship Adonis allows Damian to train
at his boxing gym under little Duke it's
not long before Damien does something
dangerous when Duke and Adonis realized
they may have made a mistake the
mistakes were made Adonis is also trying
to set up the fight of the century
bringing back Vic de Drago his Newfound
Ally to fight Felix Chavez played by
real life fighter Jose Benavides a
former welterweight champion who
actually lost only two fights in his
career one to Terence Crawford who plays
Nightmare in this movie Adonis the
sparring partner there's a little Easter
egg ready to breakdown for you Chavez
has been training at his gym under Duke
seizing this opportunity that's not
revealed until later Damien gets one of
his friends from prison to fracture
Drago's hand and arm at Bianca's label
party with no one left to fight Felix
Adonis recommends using Damien which is
not that equal of a fight seeing their
clear difference in age but as Donald
refers to it as an Underdog Story even
dropping Rocky's name uh everyone agrees
to it I would also like to add because
this is just me I got really excited
about this the singer of the label party
is kailani and I guessed in the theater
out loud just because I love her so much
moving on Felix gets his ass whooped I
know I'm sorry and sent straight to the
hospital leaving Damien the Victor and
baby it only goes uphill from there he's
immediately seen as the True Underdog
and is living the most lavish life but
also talking mad [__] on my boy Donnie
every opportunity he gets saying that
he's a coward he runs away from
everything comparing his career in
retirement to the night he was arrested
and Adonis dipped out right before this
though Marianne unfortunately passes
away she doesn't seem to be sick in
Creed 2 but by Creed 3 she had a stroke
and everyone's constantly worried about
her health she suffers another stroke
and slowly passes away in her bed with
Adonis holding her hand before going in
a hay she thinks she's talking to Apollo
and tells him once he left she found the
boy the Boy Adonis who saved her and
he's amazing so even in that fleeting
moment her last words were how proud she
was of Adonis I like to think he
resembled Apollo so much in this movie
that she literally thought she was
talking to Apollo himself maybe baby
believed she was already on the other
side with him and I think she went out
happy oh ding ding ding round four after
the funeral Adonis goes on first take
with my boy Stephen A Smith to challenge
Damien to The Ultimate Showdown at
Dodger Stadium in like Rocky we love a
training montage it's giving mountains
it's giving hiking we are polling planes
punching trees sparring with an old
enemy turned friend I'm in heaven now in
the first movie Rocky had Donnie running
around Philly and chasing chickens in
the second movie they drove to the
desert to spar with other Fighters slam
a sledgehammer into the ground and
literally shadow box a garbage fire
concrete three years have passed and
he's polling planes this man has
upgraded he's sparring with Victor Drago
how crazy is that the relationship
between him and Drago in this movie
makes me believe he'll be appearing in
the fourth Creed it's like he has
unfinished business in every move yes in
this fight you guys this is when I get
serious this fight is insane not only
did Michael B Jordan say it has anime
style inspiration that little anime geek
but it feels exactly like the ancestral
plane in Black Panther this is coogler
doing it all over again it really did I
love the fight depicted because
ultimately it's not a about the money or
the people watching it's that these two
boys settling this out for themselves
and proving something to one another
once they're alone in the ring smoke
fills the stadium the air turns gray and
the silence is just so loud you can only
hear the swings from their gloves until
the Renaissance Coral like vocals
protrude it's like watching a moving
painting the choreography feels like a
dance and it's rhythmic and beautiful
now this is a rag's richest tale of two
boys now grown into angry men angry at
their past angry at each other so during
this fight they can't help but remember
who they once were in their limitations
when flung against the ropes Damien's
back presses against jail cell bars
short glimpses of their younger cells
flash on the screen it's causing anxiety
and we all feel claustrophobic grieving
their emotions but still focused on the
fight it's always been about the fight
right no wrong it's their relationship
coogler has always been good at showing
us black men celebrating their pride and
resilience but this time he showed his
black men navigating at relationships
trauma and their emotions which I really
really like and thank God we might have
come to a neutral conclusion because I
can't stand these two brothers fighting
no no they're too handsome to fight like
Jessica said in a very anime-like
finisher Donnie knocks out Damien
holding his champion chip status luckily
it feels like their friendship wasn't
completely ruined after the fight when
they have a small heart to heart in the
locker with their signature old school
handshakes small tears run down their
faces and Donnie exits to celebrate with
Bianca and Amara so many great classic
rocky-esque moments in this film much
like Rocky III and Rocky's former
opponent and adonis's father Apollo
Creed helps Rocky defeat Mr T AKA clever
link Victor Drago is in this movie to
help Adonis win this fight now the
Adelphi gym in the movie is littered
with old posters of Adonis and Apollo's
fight adonis's childhood room has a
Naruto poster Michael B Jordan is an
anime nerd so this is obviously a nod to
that Adonis gets his Rocky running up
the stairs Moment by sprinting up The
Hollywood Hills and celebrating above
the Hollywood Sign much like Rocky 3
Adonis like Rocky has retired from
fighting is now living the High Life
only to be brought out of retirement by
a rough and tumble brawler of an
opponent adonis's comeback is fueled by
grief much like Rocky after Mick dies
now Dame beats Chavez so badly he has to
be hospitalized it's a slightly more
mild version of Drago killing Apollo in
Rocky IV absolutely and you guys that's
it for our little video our little
breakdown on Creed 3. genuinely we're
excited for more keep Michael B Jordan
fighting forever I always say go watch
Creed 3 again and let us know how you
felt about it in the comments follow
follow us at Lulu underscore Clemons and
Tommy Beck told follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love tune
enjoy sister Channel The Deep dive for
Eric's deep analysis his next video is
on Back to the Future thanks for
watching peace out
foreign